I think people get into reality TV and
get incredibly damaged and don't know
what they're getting into couldn't agree
more yeah you were in it yeah did you
feel that pressure what how what
pressure like what kind what do you mean
I felt a lot of pressure yeah but I
think most of the the damage and the
pressure comes
from the aftermath of the show right
listen I I'm not on every production set
out there so I can't speak to the
working conditions that are going on um
but do know they're pretty upfront with
what people are signing up for at least
to the extent of you're that doesn't
mean that doesn't mean anything though
well to a certain extent you know well
I'll just give you what what I do know
I'm on America's Got Talent and on
American America's Got Talent we have
employed a
full-time um therapist or psychologist
or and and and they're always there
they're always in the wings and that is
because people have signed contracts and
they're going to go out there I don't
think we can explain ad nauseum what
you're about to do you are you are going
out there in front of millions of people
in front of a panel of uh judges in
front of a live audience and you
hopefully will achieve your your hopes
and your
dreams um things don't always go as
planned corre yeah and many times many
times
how those people or groups of people
react to how they are
received or how they perceive they're
being received um in a in a very um
vulnerable scary way so that you know
there is somebody as they walk off that
stage saying are you as somebody
professional are you okay do you need to
talk about something are you okay with
everything that just happened are you
sure and we take the responsibility of
uh making sure they're at least seem
okay when they leave the building yeah
to that end my uh my headset just
unplugged to that
end I can't imagine there isn't a
psychologist sitting on the is there one
sitting there at the
bachelor I uh yes there is when I I
don't when I was on they had one on on
staff and traveled with the show okay I
I don't think they were made available
to the cast as much as I think they
should have uh I think and then post
show the therapist was in theory always
available but again not to the extent in
which I think they should be since then
my understanding is they have um
drastically improved that I think they
have kind of like what they call like an
after Care Program which should exist
because even more than on AGT and they
don't let anybody leave the building
without at least a professional
believing that they are in a safe place
mentally um I think that sometimes when
you're on a reality show um your context
is only where you are and and and what
you see and what you hear as opposed to
when it airs you know you don't know
what somebody else said in their uh in
their interview or how they took your
date or how they did that and then you
see that and that could impact you and
there's nobody sitting beside you at
home to go I came off like a [__]
idiot totally or or maybe you didn't or
were made to look like you came off like
an idiot
right